can we all just get along or are
Americans in the midst of a cold civil
war as Democrats amp up their assault
against noted cocaine kingpin Mitch
McConnell and all of the other
Republicans he represents conciliatory
conservatives are missing the only
possible strategy for domestic peace we
will analyze then a look around the most
important midterm races the similarities
between Nazis and the weather thank you
to Alexandria Cassio Cortes and most
shocking of all CNN does something
worthwhile
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael no luck
we're talking about war today we are
talking about war fresh on the heels of
politican where I don't feel like
reconciling anything at all we will talk
about the cold civil where I've avoided
talking about this because I think it's
typically exaggerated political rhetoric
now I'm not so sure
as people are assaulting cocaine Mitch
at restaurants I'm not so sure so we'll
look at it but first let's make a little
money honey let's do it because we're
not gonna win the cold Civil War if we
don't extol the virtues of capitalism
and you know me how long do I spend
sleeping every day 17 18 hours I need it
it's my beauty wrist thank goodness I
have Boleyn branch sheets Boleyn branch
sheets are so good
when I was a slum in it as a bachelor I
would just buy the cheapest sheets in
the world you know sandpaper basically a
bowl and branch sheets makes FF from
bedding to blankets everything is made
from 100% organic cotton they start off
super soft they get even softer over
time really nice premium sheets you know
at those five-star hotels that can cost
a thousand dollars in the store Boleyn
branch or only about a couple hundred
dollars that's why three u.s. presidents
sleep on them everybody who tries Boleyn
branch loves them including little old
me they have thousands of five-star
reviews Forbes The Wall Street Journal
Fast Company are all talking about it to
get started you can get shipping for
free you can try them for 30 nights if
you don't love them send them back for a
refund you're not gonna want to send
them back they're so so good it's the
only reason sweet little ELISA hasn't
moved out yet is my Boleyn branch sheets
get $50 off your first set of sheets at
Bowman branch com promo code Michael
don't say I never did nothing for you
Boleyn branch comm today $50 off your
first set of sheets enter my boudoir
feel what it is like
vol L and branch comm promo code Michael
mi CH AE l don't spell it like you're a
barista at some coffee companies fell it
correctly mi CH AE L I have avoided this
rhetoric this civil Cold War I know a
lot of other people on the right and on
the left have talked about it I'm
beginning to wonder if they if they want
a war maybe they can have a war you know
you've got Democrat elected officials
calling for violence against the GOP and
then a politican where we all were
yesterday I was there I was on a panel
which is called how the bleep do we all
get along and talking to the lefties on
that panel
I'm more and more convinced that they
are really calling for a cultural and a
cold civil war and no less than Carl
Bernstein a lefty journalist on CNN is
saying the same thing here is we are in
a cold Civil War in this country then
these two events both the Muller
investigation and the Cavanaugh
nomination are almost the the Gettysburg
and Antietam the the the absolutely
essential battles of this cold Civil War
Gettysburg and Antietam that rhetoric is
about as hot as you can possibly get and
so if they want a cold Civil War they're
gonna get it you K if an aggressor is
saying we're gonna be fighting you we're
declaring war on you then you can't
ignore it you can't say that there is no
war and you've obviously got Maxine
Waters calling for elected air for
Democratic supporters to attack
Republicans at their homes Eric Holder
the same thing Hillary Clinton the same
thing so maybe we've got to start taking
this seriously why are they doing this
first why all of this talk of the cold
Civil War it's because they have no
issues they actually are running on this
election on no issues what are they
fighting for I guess there's a little
vague talk about health care but even
that is very vague they're not pushing
any particular policy are they running
on immigration no because that's a huge
loser issue for Democrats even among
Democrat primary voters that's a big
loser issue the economy is doing very
well we have relative peace abroad
we've got virtually no unemployment what
is the issue this might be the first
issue free election in a long time so
it's just all about Trump they're just
talking about how much they hate Donald
Trump I was on this panel you know and
it was me Charlie Kirk you know also on
the right roaming millennial who's on
the show and then a couple of lefties
Kyle kolinsky is secular talk on YouTube
and this guy Bakari sellers who he was
the one who went on CNN and said that
Kanye West is what happens when Negroes
don't read books he's that guy I think
we talked about him on the show and you
know one thing I noticed is that some
conservatives at politican wanted to
conciliate they wanted to give some
concessions to the left they were
talking about areas where open
servants can abandon our ideas and let's
just embrace left-wing ideas oh we don't
we don't need the death penalty we don't
look there's always been disagreement on
the right over the death penalty but
there were some people saying no we
don't let's get rid of that let's drop
that issue we can go further to the left
on it oh how about criminal jets like
criminals out of prison yeah we can let
some criminals out of prison that's
that's fun we have too many people in
prison okay
oh the drug war has been a big loss see
we're getting together and the I don't
know what the thought is here for one
maybe genuinely these people are more
libertarian on another level maybe they
think that the left is going to give
them credit for this the left won't give
you credit they will not give you credit
you cannot make the New York Times like
you they will never like you they will
use you but they will never like you and
and I obviously John McCain has fallen
into this trap
Mitt Romney fell into this trap we
should not fall into this trap you know
that the lesson of the Trump era is to
fight but don't give in don't be squishy
don't say oh well I didn't I didn't
strap my dog to the roof of my car and
oh no don't fight because we're winning
and the voters actually rewarded you
when you fight when you stand up to
these guys and you make fun of Jim
Acosta they reward you it's not a
liability it's a real advantage I have
the strategy I'm you know that they were
asking how do we all get along how do we
move along and get along and I'll give
this and you give that if we have a
civil Cold War
here is my strategy we win and they lose
those aren't my words that was Ronald
Reagan's words on the first Cold War the
actual cold war with the Soviet Union he
said here's my strategy we win and they
lose and he was pilloried for this he
said oh he's not being sophisticated and
his thorough is not he's a cowboy he's a
madman no that's the answer that you
cannot conciliate here you know there
was a there there this little little
Catholic corner there was this Pope
Blessed Pius the ninth who when they
gave up all the papal states this the
the Pope had killed a lot of people and
executed a lot of criminals and the last
criminal said please please don't
execute me and he said I cannot move
here's your execution and I do not want
to that is how I feel about this
I cannot conciliate on the cold cultural
war and I do not
- I do why would we how are how are we
gonna meet in the middle on really
hot-button radical social issues where
do we meet in the middle an abortion
abortion was the the center of the fight
for Brett Cavanaugh's nomination it was
all about roe v-- wade they made up
these things about women and when he was
15 in 1982 it was all about Roe vs. Wade
where is the conciliation one side says
we shouldn't kill unborn babies the
other side says we should kill unborn
babies up until right before birth
abortion on demand paid for by taxpayers
where is the conciliation that is
actually the perfect example of trying
to split the baby you can't split the
baby why would you the the right is in
the right on this they're in the right
morally but they're in the right
politically to pro-life cause has gained
a lot of traction since Roe vs. Wade
it's at historical high levels of
support why would you give up on that on
a question like the redefinition of
marriage where the Supreme Court Anthony
Kennedy yanks that issue out of the
public sphere and says you can't debate
this anymore because I Anthony Kennedy
will wax poetic about the the
constitutional right to intimacy or
whatever they made up there which
Antonin Scalia made fun of in his
dissent where is the conciliation do we
say okay well the Supreme Court can
redefine certain essential human
institutions but not others oh well
maybe okay here so radical leftists want
to redefine marriage to include you know
polygamists who knows what unions and
normal people say that marriage has a
meaning and sexual difference in here is
in the definition of marriage so okay
maybe it'll be three people of various
no there's no conciliation we're talking
about the meaning of words where is that
where's the conciliation on any other
policy on foreign policy and domestic
affairs on deregulation one side says we
want the government to have less control
over your life and we want them to have
more accountability the other side says
we want to give more and more power more
and more of your money more and more
control of your life to the federal
government there's no conciliation there
and also why would have you noticed that
the left only calls for conciliation
when they're losing when we're advancing
we're advancing right
we are winning I mean this has been
building for for a long time this has
been building since 2010 or you know
after the Obama election in 2008 2010 we
win the house after that we win the
Senate we win the state houses we win
the governorship
this is capped off by the election of
Trump in 2016 we take the White House
we've got everything Anthony Kennedy
believes that the Supreme Court we get a
more originalist judge which changes the
balance of the court we are winning and
all of a sudden the left says oh no no
now we need to get along well where were
you six years ago pals
where were you when Barack Obama was
painting the White House in rainbow
colors we were you saying we need to be
nice to one another and meet in the
middle then I don't think so it's so
cynical it's such a cynical and such a
transparent strategy look at what
they're doing on the cold Civil War look
at what some hysterical millennial is
doing to Pablo Escobar himself cocaine
Mitch just trying to have a dinner with
his wife at a restaurant
are you gonna compromise with that are
you gonna compromise with some
hysterical Millennials like going up to
his table wait why don't you leave why
don't you just go on and leave the whole
country
no how about I don't know about you sit
down you hysterical child and I will
finish my meal I also love cocaine Mitch
this is how you know he's been the head
of the mid-eighteen cartel for a very
long time
he doesn't even flinch when this guy
comes up ko is just there he's just got
his mound of you know booger sugar in
front of him or so I don't know what he
ordered for dinner but he's just there
he does not even flinch this is a
parable for the country because this
hysterical millennial gets up he says
why don't you leave why don't you leave
and then everyone in the restaurant who
was just minding their own business just
sitting there trying to get on with
their lives they turn Elysees shut up
sit down why are you that this is what
we see with with voters you know you've
got this hysterical group of people with
the pink hats screaming ripping up signs
kicking people okay there aren't that
many of them and I think for a long time
because the left had a monopoly over the
media had a monopoly over the means of
communication we thought that not only
were they half the country that they
were the majority of the country that
Walter Cronkite world Federalist
left-wing or Walter Cronkite he was the
voice of the American people not the
case and once he got a little freedom in
there and a little bit of new media we
learned that that wasn't the case I
think most of America or those diners
sitting there just trying to eat who
were getting increasingly annoyed by
these insane largely millennial people
and I think that this is a millennial
problem you don't see older generations
doing this so much going up to the
tables shrieking at Ted Cruz and
restaurants going to people's houses you
know Millennials are a coddled
generation there have been many books
written about this John Haight has
written about this a lot of politicians
have talked about it it's a coddled
generation it's the participation trophy
generation they got everything they
wanted they were helicopter parented
sure I mean that it's all it's not even
really their fault that's just how they
were parented it's how they were brought
up that when they got to high school in
college they were indoctrinated in
leftist ideology that just confirmed the
biases that they were raised
and presented any other point of view as
evil or wicked and outside of the realm
of public debate and even politically
they always got what they wanted by the
time the Millennials came of age what
did they do they elected Barack Obama
and Barack Obama reigned as king for
eight years for the first time they
didn't get what they wanted in their
being behaving like children and we've
got to treat them like children I know I
don't mean that you've got to be cruel
you don't want to be cruel to a child
you don't want to torture a child but
you've got to be firm you've got to take
a stand you don't compromise with the
child the teacher doesn't compromise
with the child the director of the
insane institution doesn't compromise
with the inmates you have to stand firm
it's the only way that you're gonna help
people get a little bit better
unfortunately for our friends on the
Left they're not learning this lesson if
you look at these races around the
country the polls are getting really
interesting in Indiana now Indiana was
really one of these swing Senate seats
obviously the the Cavanaugh effect has
been pretty profound in North Dakota
we've talked about Heidi Heitkamp up
there but in Indiana it was really
really close and now Mike Braun the
Republican is a leading Senator Joe
Donnelly by four points so you're now
getting a little little past the margin
of error depending on which poll you're
looking at all of the analysts are
attributing this to the Cavanaugh effect
and what is the Cavanaugh effect what
did the Cavanaugh effect show it's when
a mob of Democrats decided to institute
lynch mob justice on a guy who did not
have due process based on accusations
that were pretty flimsy they reacted
against that they revolted against that
that you've got the Hetu movement out of
it you know because women have husbands
and wives and fathers what why would we
why would we give up now that we're
winning why would we pull back now now
is the time to charge even harder
especially that now that you've got
midterm elections coming up so if you if
you turn down to Florida there was this
debate I know you didn't watch it won
cuz it was on CNN and too because it was
so hard to watch Andrew Gilliam the
Democrat this Democrat actual socialist
out-and-out socialist guy against Ronda
Sanchez their Republican if you didn't
catch it there there are a few really
good clips of it and DeSantis mop the
or with the guy so what does Andrew
Gilliam do
he immediately resorts to the oldest
democrat tactic in the book he plays the
race card here they are did you pay for
the Hamilton ticket or did the
undercover FBI pay for the Hamilton
ticket did you pay to stay on the under
the villa in Costa Rica
where are the receipts you have not
proven that you paid for anything and
that's the problem so here's the direct
answer I don't take free trips from
anybody I'm a hardworking person I know
that may not fit your description of
what you think people like me do but I
worked hard for everything that I've
gotten in my life and I don't need
anybody handing me anything for free it
might not fit your description of what
people like me do if he's referring to
Socialists he's absolutely right I don't
know many hard-working socialists but
that's not what he means he's saying I'm
a black guy and you're saying that black
people are lazy no you're saying that
black people are lazy he didn't say that
at all what he said is that you took
gifts from lobbyists which you didn't
even deny you notice that Andrew Gilliam
can't deny it
so the allegation that DeSantis makes is
that Gilliam took free Broadway tickets
to Hamilton which by the way as a New
Yorker I can tell you the price on those
is like seven zillion dollars per ticket
you know it's that that was the hottest
ticket in town and then he went on some
trip and had things bought for him by by
some lobbyist and so what does Andrew
Gilliam do he immediately just twists it
he says I never have people pay for my
trips well do you have people pay for
part of your trips do you have people
pay for certain things on your trips do
you have people sent who knows and he
also just won't acknowledge the the
Broadway thing he won't acknowledge the
Hamilton tickets and then all he does is
he turns it on race he says are you
you're saying black people are lazy no
I'm saying you or a crook you are
corrupt he had no answer to that and
DeSantis also didn't get put off by the
race comment you know this is what they
do as an Coulter told me when I was a
wee young lad of 18 in college she said
when a liberal calls you a racist you
know that you've won the argument I saw
this a politican yesterday I was on this
panel with I was it was roaming
Millenial that was the only way it was
bearable a John Fugelsang who I sort of
liked though he was making very stupid
points and the person to my
right was this alleged comedian Randy
Sklar I think he has a YouTube channel
to scull our brothers and this guy he
tried to land a couple punches he was
really angry he was coming out strong as
I hate Trump and babe and you know he
made some allegation about Donald Trump
having business interests in Saudi
Arabia I pointed out that Saudi Arabia
gave a bunch of money to the Clintons he
had no answer because all he had are
these talking points so he says all of
these talking points and then once he
ran out of talking points what did he do
he called me a racist which is how you
know that you win the argument when you
when you can't refute the claim when you
can't attack the claim attack the person
and it's really it's really disgusting I
mean we're so used to it by now that I
think we forget how awful that is in
modern America there is nothing worse
that you can be called than a racist
there's nothing worse you KITT is a
synonym for evil it is a it is to say
you're an evil person you're an evil
person I mean we shouldn't brush it off
I so we get so calloused because we're
so used to them saying that all the time
but it's really awful and we should we
should fight him back tooth and nail cuz
that's not very conciliatory language
that's not really let's all get along
kind of language is it so-so DeSantis
was great on that point he also goes on
and gets to the essential issue the
essential actual policy issue of these
midterm elections and I think it's a big
winner for Republicans I think the
Democrats are running scared here it is
you honor a request from Donald Trump's
ice agency if they provide a detainer
request will you honor it as governor
will you work with Donald Trump you
proceed with your time you won't answer
the Jake that's important because that's
what happens when somebody I've been a
prosecutor I've worked with law
enforcement when they're in the system
they're convicted that maybe they serve
10 years but it comes time to come out
there's a detainer request from ice you
either turn them over to ice or release
them into the community that's the only
two options
Andrew will not answer the question that
tells me let me would be willing to
release them to the well of course III
just think that this showboating is
unnecessary oh do you the guy who's
playing the race card not five seconds
before
who's saying that De Santis thinks black
people are lazy now it's all I don't
know why we should be showboating I love
to they fall silent when you try to pin
them down on any issue of policy
especially in the question of
immigration
he says DeSantis says would you turn the
criminals over to law enforcement or
would you release them into the
community and there's that moment of
silence and Gilliam says well no go on
no no no god I don't wanna interrupt
well you wanted to interrupt on all the
other questions why that's interesting
you've fallen silent on that question of
immigration and we know that immigration
is a big winner I can't tell if our
friends on the left are obtuse on this
or if they're genuinely ignorant the
reason that illegal immigration is a big
winner issue is not because illegal
immigration depresses wages it's not
because illegal immigrants take welfare
at higher rates it's not even that
illegal immigrants commit crimes certain
crimes at higher rates it's actually not
that it's because it is an offense to
the country itself it is an offense to
the integrity of the country the very
fact of the nation when you have people
disrespecting your borders crossing back
and forth willy-nilly coming over here
and demanding that you give them
something it is so offensive and it puts
Democrats in this awful position where
Democrats are now being held hostage by
their base if Andrew Gilliam were just
strictly looking at the numbers he would
come out and say oh I'd turn them over
to law enforcement I deport half the
illegal aliens in this country i deport
all of the criminal the violent criminal
illegal aliens I'd get really tough on
it why because we know from the from the
public opinion polling and from
elections that that's a big winner issue
not just among Republicans if there was
a poll taken at the beginning of the
year that showed the majority of
Democrat voters did not believe that
amnesty even for dreamers so-called
even for young illegal aliens brought
here before they were old enough to
think that that should be a top priority
for a congress even among Democrat
voters so if he saw that he would just
answer and it would be a gimme but he
can't because they're held hostage by
that base that screaming little
millennial who goes up to cocaine Mitch
and yells in his face that that guy that
small
of democrats is the democrat base and
they go out and they write checks and
they signed petitions and they carry
petitions and they go canvass and
they're the activists and they're
increasingly at odds with other swaths
of the Democrat voter base so right now
president Trump has made great strides
he in particular though it's true from
Republicans broadly among black voters
and among Hispanic voters the black
black voter support has more than
doubled Hispanic voter support has
surged in that and that does have tails
for repor other Republicans as well
Democrats can't afford to lose those
demographics they've relied on huge
portions of those demographics for years
but the minute that they start speaking
on issues that those bases care about
they lose their activists they lose the
people who go at it's a really tough
position that they're in and it's why
Andrew Gilliam finally mercifully fell
silent
so what issues can they run on they
can't run on immigration they'll lose
they can't run on taxes they'll lose
which is why the Republicans are
doubling down now you're saying oh yeah
you like that tax cut we'll give you
another one this is a really something I
find charming about President Trump's
political I don't call it naivete but
you know he's not the subtlest guy in
the world is you know a really crafty
sophisticated politician he'd say okay
how am i gonna package this to look like
this and then but President Trump it
seems like someone gave him a sheet that
said tax cuts popular is like doing more
tax cuts to more tax cuts I'll give you
more tax cuts because they're popular
it's like this that really that honest
you know you know what the strategy is
you know what you're getting and we'll
we'll get to the advantages of that in a
second so they can't run on that they
can't run on the taxes they can't run on
joblessness which basically doesn't
exist so what are they gonna run on the
Sun monster they're gonna run on the
boogeyman hiding underneath the earth
that then rises up and threatens to kill
us all they're trying to run on global
warming so fortunately we can turn out
of the thought leader of the Democrat
Party to use Steve Hayward's nickname
for her Alexandria occasional cortex who
has the American strategy on fighting
the Sun monster
well
before
or we
at this time Nazi Germany attacks that
millions of people to work with bending
our shores
we could get her there I've had enough
Alexandria occasional cortex so she said
just that last bit she says we put
hundreds of thousands of people if maybe
millions to work defending our country
16 million Americans served in World War
two just think if she's gonna use this
talking point you would have like
googled basic facts of World War two but
that's fine
she says that the strategy to fight the
Sun Monster this strategy to fight
global warming is the same strategy that
we use to fight the Nazis by which I
assume she means evacuate Dunkirk and
storm the beaches of Normandy I would
just we've never tried that we've tried
capping fuel emissions
we've tried banning certain plastics but
we've never tried evacuating Dunkirk and
storming Normandy so maybe that will
work
maybe that's what they'll do if the
Democrats win the house ironically the
other strategy that we would use if the
the way to fight global warming is the
same as how we fought the Nazis is to
collude with the Russians we could not
have defeated the Nazis if we didn't
collude with the Russians and it would
be a beautiful about-face it would be
Nixon going to China if the Democrats
came into the house
after the midterm elections and they
said you know what we're gonna do guys
we've been wrong about this let's start
colluding with Russia something tells me
they're not going to do that though so
obviously this is absurd her answer here
is absurd that's why everybody's making
fun of it but the issue is absurd the
issue of global warming is absurd
I'm sorry global cooling oh I'm sorry
climate change oh I'm sorry this that or
the other thing it's it this is the this
is where the the left
whips itself up into a religious frenzy
you hear all the time about the
religious right this is the religious
left because it's unfalsifiable the cult
of global warming it's unscientific
anytime the reality doesn't match the
computer models and the scientific
models for warming they just adjust the
models and they adjust their view of
reality to match the scientific models
you've had the IPCC the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change come out and say that greenhouse
gases do not have a significant
correlation to warming and that there
hasn't been significant warming in a
while they've had to adjust so many of
their graphs so this is all they've got
like bad
or powerpoints from 2006 that is the
best that they can run on a good
situation for for Republicans in this
election
who knows when if the economy cracks up
or something then the Democrats finally
have an issue again but for right now
they're running on nothing which is why
all they're doing is talking in slogans
and talking about themselves to turn to
another Democrat tribe this time in
Massachusetts
laia Wafaa has been stepping in it on
this DNA question so she can't shut up
about it sadly and sadly for her good
for us here is lieth are trying to
defend it again after defending it
before Senator when we spoke in March
for an interview and I asked you about
whether or not you would take a DNA test
you will you told me that you believe
that the issue of your Native American
heritage
had been settled why did you change your
mind and recently release the results of
a DNA test you know one of the things I
see now is that confidence in government
is at an all-time low and I believe one
way that we try to rebuild confidence is
through transparency ultimately I took a
DNA test because I am an open book and
it's all out there it's on the internet
anybody can take a look because at the
end of the day this isn't about me this
is about what's happening to working
families all across this Commonwealth
this isn't about me at the end of the
day and that's why I have spent three
weeks now exclusively talking about
myself and not just about myself and how
I look and how I speak but actually the
DNA at the core of myself I've been
talking about my genetic code because
this this isn't about me this is about
something else that I don't want to talk
about right now so it's not about me
really said also that voice that why you
know Trump talked about that face I
don't know about that face I just that
voice makes our president sound like a
songbird it makes our senators it makes
Ted Cruz sound like a songbird she and
I'm not saying it's because of the
particular tenor of her voice it's
because she has that
politician voice or that old politician
voice you know where it's a little
breathy and it's a practiced and
emotional speech eeeh and it's it's just
awful it's so grating cory booker has
turned that up to 11 in his Spartacus
moments and his tears of rage I don't
know where they think that this is going
to help them in 2020 but I think that
voice is kind of over now because you
know when Trump came out in 2016 and
just talked like a brash guy from Queens
who didn't use the right words and often
said things that were offensive to both
his opponents and his supporters I think
it cracked that up a little bit I think
people like a straight talk if you will
Blount speech at least how else do you
explain Michael avenatti getting on the
TV networks a Michael avenatti for all
of his flaws he does speak plainly he
probably speaks a little too plainly
that worth mercifully I think that voice
is over because the trouble with that
voice too is you're constantly having to
figure out what they're actually saying
like the old joke I would think about
this whenever I heard a politician say
like you know we need to lower your
taxes not raise your taxes it was
whatever they said after not was the
thing they were actually gonna do it was
such a lie it was a voice and addiction
of such lies that they would do that and
fortunately now we've got Republicans
who actually do what they say for better
or worse and I just think it really
falls flat then she goes on with pure
grade-a Liz Warren and lieth a Democrat
sanctimony give it to me I I'm a kid who
wanted to be a public school teacher and
by the time I graduated from high school
we don't have the money for a college
application much less a chance for me to
actually go to college a lot of twists
and turns in my story but my big chance
was a commuter college that costs 50
dollars a semester and it opened a
million doors for me I am the daughter
of someone who ended up as a janitor and
I got to be a professor in a United
States Senator okay blah blah blah my
mother washed more floors for less money
than your mother blah blah blah that's
what she's doing is a classic
both parties do it but this is
especially a classic Democrat strategy
John Kasich famously did in 2016
do you remember his father's a mailman
did you know that John Kasich father was
a mailman Liz Warren I think almost
mentioned it but I want to direct your
attention to one little phrase in in her
soliloquy here she says so you know I
couldn't want it to be a schoolteacher I
just wanted to do this and you know
college was there were a lot of twists
and turns in my life and then I
succeeded so those twists and turns
which he's talked about twists and turns
she's saying that she got married and
then her husband paid for her law school
and then she cheated on her husband
while she was in law school and then she
left her husband and six months later
married her law professor and now and
then she had her career those are the
twists and turns and I don't point that
out to cast stones at Elizabeth Warren
politicians are often rotten dirty
people and they do rotten dirty things
everybody's got a past and everybody
makes mistakes that's not what I'm
saying I'm doing it to point out the
hypocrisy in the sanctimony of Democrats
critics of the president critics of
other Republicans in the news media who
focus on every one of president from
sexual misdeeds of which there are many
they focus on all of the president's
failed marriages but they don't point
this at they let her get away with
twists and turns twists and turns she
leaves her husband cheats on her husband
leaves her husband marries her law
professor leaves the guy who paid for
her law school and so it's just twists
and turns how brave how powerful there
was an article that came out did you
know obviously a praising Elizabeth
Warren in the mainstream media and they
said Elizabeth Warren's biggest mistake
so I figured this would be an article
about how she left her husband and you
know but look people make big mistakes
in life okay no no no the big mistake
was marrying her husband in the first
place her first husband that was the
mistake because if not for that she
would be st. Elizabeth the great the
Great Spirit Leah whathe but she has
that and they bury it they don't focus
on it at all and just that oh gosh I
really can't stand that my mother washed
more floors for less money I don't know
that that play is now either you know if
a Mitt Romney in 2012 had just come out
and said I'm a rich guy
I have a lot of money my dad was a rich
guy and I'm a richer guy and yeah I go
on vacation and I have elevators in my
house cuz I'm a rich guy don't you want
to be like me I'm a rich cool guy it
would have played it would have played
so much better then saying well I'm not
that rich and I drew well we had to do
this for that and this Anna doesn't work
stop conceding stop conceding points
that you don't have to when your
opponent is running away when you were
advancing it doesn't make any sense we
have got a lot more to talk about
especially down in Texas with my buddy
bata O'Rourke he's got a new song and
dance number that it's really gonna take
Texas by a storm probably just Austin if
you know what I'm talking about but
you've got to go to daily wire.com if
you want to do that what do you get well
if you missed politican over the weekend
you can go over there now and see all of
the great daily wire activity from
politican that's for subscribers you can
enjoy all the leftist tears produced
over the weekend what else do you get
you get me you get the under Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you get to
ask questions in the mailbag that's
coming up so make sure you get your
mailbag questions in get to ask
questions in the conversation you get
another Kingdom another Kingdom Andrew
Clavin this narrative podcast that
little ol me performs all the roles in
subscribers get that on Mondays get to
see all the beautiful art nonsubscribers
have to wait like seven or eight years I
think or just until that Friday to get
the audio none of that matters this
matters you know there have been a lot
of twists and turns in my life but a lot
of twists and turns and are in the
political life of our country but one
thing that has always sustained me
sustained all of us are those salty
frothy delicious leftist tears and you
can enjoy them in the only fda-approved
vessel for leftist tears the leftist
years tumblr go to daily wire calm get
it we'll be right back
back to Texas you know we've talked
about Indiana we've talked about the
Massachusetts we've talked about some
races but you knew that I wasn't going
to leave you without an update on beta
or Roark my pal
before we talk about him in particular
just look at how ABC News mainstream
media news network
treats Democrat candidates like Oh work
or work is kind of the special case but
he exemplifies how they treat all
Democrats this is on the trail according
to ABC on the trail with Ted Cruz and
beta O'Rourke one of the most simple
obvious strategies that I've seen
employed in a modern campaign we just
literally show up everywhere all the
time for everyone you can't go ten feet
without an interruption from a beto
backer I love you too thank you all
you're a rock star no I know there's
just so many great people work a
three-term congressman from El Paso has
certainly captured the entire nation's
attention as well
oh he's captured the entire nation's
attention oh he's making certain female
news anchors just go a little hot under
the collar oh who does anybody have a
little fainting couch for me yeah okay
and she goes and she said oh you're a
rock story's oh stop it stop it I'm not
how much of a rock star
oh they love you wherever you go by the
way he's walking through a bar he's just
like he said some campaign event they
were I don't know a hundred people there
or something so you're like a rock star
cuz you have any supporters at all in a
Senate campaign that you've raised 40
million dollars for therefore you're a
rough mostly national by the way yeah
you've gotta take a look at the money
that comes from out of state as well as
in from Texas
the Democrats are betting big on this
race that right now the polling doesn't
seem so great
that he's a rock star okay how did the
mainstream media cover a president
Trump's rally cuz President Trump has a
rally now in Texas and he's got more
than just a hundred people waving at him
in a bar he has people I think about a
what was it a thousand people camping
out overnight 24 hours before his rally
so that they can get in here just take a
little this is from the campaign
Facebook pages
a little glimpse of part of the
encampment trying to get tickets for
this show
you go on
that that doesn't even begin to show
everybody I mean this goes on and on and
on this is actually what happens for
rock stars and look this is the great
advantage of from the disadvantage is
that he turns everything into a reality
TV show and people say it's tawdry or
it's not elevated or it's not what our
founders envisioned for the executive
okay fair enough I totally get it the
plus side is you got a rock star as
president you've got a showman you've
got the greatest showman of his age and
you've got these be a thousand people
camping out overnight in maggots waving
that flag with the picture of Trump on a
tank like shooting fireworks I mean this
is like you know living inside an
American Pie in the fourth of July level
of excitement and patriotism they don't
call him a rock star though do they no
they don't they don't call him a rock
star they call beta O'Rourke our our
rock star you know they're the GOP is
not gonna get fair treatment and so back
on this oh how do we all get along how
do we get back to some standard of
objectivity in our discourse in our news
media they don't want that they never
wanted that their particular want to
bring you back to a time that never
existed a mythical time when the news
people were objective and they were just
getting the facts and they treated both
sides fairly they never treated both
sides fairly they would huff and puff
and go red in the face and get so
excited when they are around Democrat
candidates and they would distort the
views of conservatives not just
politicians but rank-and-file activists
and thought leaders as well you know
that they tell you I saw this yesterday
I'm one of the panels with Bakari
sellers from CNN and Kyle kolinsky this
YouTube lefty and they they do it so
well especially Bakari is very good at
this they sit there and they say you
know look I just think we all need to
come together we just need to come
together I think we can finally you know
admit that we need to you know
socialized healthcare and open our
reporters up to everybody and impeach
the president and raise taxes you know
just issues that we can all agree on you
know we just think they do it they put
on their serious face they put on their
objective face and then they try to push
radical left ISM we shouldn't buy it any
more we should we should laugh at that
we should laugh at the force that the
left-wing media have made of themselves
speaking of
they bado has a new a new campaign theme
a new motif that's gone around about
these are a bunch of bata supporters
rallying in a park
I'll let the clip speak for itself
The Village People
that's betta you know nothing says Texas
like a bunch of leather daddy gay pop
stars singing about hanging around this
fits at the YMCA
nothing says Texas right that's that I
don't know who is writing these campaign
strategies but this really illustrates
it because I bet that this is about as
close to grassroots as you get for a
Democrat campaign in Texas you know
there weren't and maybe 100 people there
or something like that and these guys
really think that they are speaking for
everybody they really think that this is
the cultural wave that they won the
culture war 30 years ago and we all just
have to go along with it and
increasingly because they're in their
own little echo chambers they've lost
that control over the culture they've
lost all of it and so they think that
going out in ponchos in in the middle of
Texas and singing the YMCA is somehow
cool or somehow rallying or a semi
encouraging we're also kind of old you
know they're all about I don't mean to
be mean to these people but that isn't
cool it isn't cool to see a bunch of 50
year olds dancing around a park to 1970s
pop music so that's what that's what
they think I don't there might be an
esoteric message here for Elizabeth
Warren because I'm I'm pretty sure the
Native American from the Village People
is like orders of magnitude more Indian
than senator Lee OWASA
but who knows I don't know I haven't I
haven't seen his DNA test maybe hook
them out with a DNA test sometime soon I
have a sign of the apocalypse for you
which is speaking of CNN I'm going to
say something nice about CNN I know I
know
pull over your car puller I know get
strap yourself in because I actually saw
something on CNN today that I sort of
liked and it proved to me why we're
never gonna get any more of it Jared
Kushner sat down to talk Middle East
policy and specifically the u.s.
relationship with Saudi Arabia he sat
down with very far left
commentator Van Jones here was just a
little tiny clip of their discussion
let's just stay with it so I mean you
said that you're gonna try to get to the
facts do you trust the Saudis to
investigate them
I mean it seems like NBS is like the
prime suspect he's also the prime
investigator I mean do you trust the
Saudis to sort this out yeah like I said
I mean we're getting facts in from
multiple places and then once those
facts come in the Secretary of State
will will will work with our national
security team to help us determine what
we want to believe in and what we think
is credible on what we think is not
credible even even Trump says it's like
deception and lies I mean do you I mean
you you do you see anything that it
seems deceptive I see things that are
deceptive every day I see them in the
Middle East I see him in Washington and
so again I think that we have our eyes
wide open oh is that is that I'm
actually I'm joking there because I
actually really liked this interview I
thought it was a very good interview
I thought Jared Kushner explained the
position of the administration very well
he was very articulate he had a pretty
clear idea as he just said he said the
administration he has a clear-eyed view
and the administration is taking a
clear-eyed view towards Saudi Arabia and
I thought Van Jones did very well
Van Jones is a far left guy but he's at
least smart and he can be it serious
when he wants to be and this was a
serious discussion he wasn't trying to
slam him or have a gotcha moment or
twist his words or be unfair he actually
was pushing him he was asking pretty
tough questions but he was giving
Kushner a chance to explain the policy
of the administration and we actually
got something out of it I I now can see
the Saudi policy you know the policy
toward Saudi Arabia a little more
clearly I can see a little bit where the
White House is going and what they're
thinking and who's doing it and so good
on Van Jones good on CNN for airing it
they're never going to do it again
they're never gonna do it again the only
reason I saw this clip is because it was
trending on Twitter it was trending
because the left-wing base the CNN
audience will actually by CNN audience
the only people who actually watch CNN
regularly are commuters in airports
because it without airport TV is having
CNN on the network would go bankrupt but
the five people who watch CNN were
furious and then the left-wing that saw
CNN saw this clip going around were
furious that ban Jones didn't get up and
punch Jared in the face
because you can't be civil to Republican
says Hillary clean kick them in the face
says Eric Holder go attack them at their
homes and their kids and apparently
their son-in-law says Maxine Waters so
they were so furious that we actually
got a serious discussion out of it you
know people blame politicians for the
kind of politicians they are they blame
the media for the kind of media that
they get you you get what you want in in
this life you get what you want and if
you the reason that we elect certain
people to represent us is because those
people are behaving in a way that can
convince us to vote for them the the the
founders and the framers were very wise
when they created the House of
Representatives and the House of
Representatives represents the passions
of the people so when you look at your
politicians and you're disgusted by them
take a look in the mirror because you're
you're looking at it you're looking at
people who are behaving in a way such
that you're incentivized to vote for
them and to keep them in office and it's
the same thing with the media you know
the one thing I noticed a politican is
that the lefties there were not
sophisticated thinkers I'm trying to say
this in a nice way that doesn't sound
very arrogant they had bad arguments if
they had arguments at all
they weren't addressing questions they
were making absurd logical fallacies and
that's the audience that's the audience
for the left that's the audience for CNN
and so there's no incentive to do that
fortunately we have a new media that
hasn't totally been censored so you can
get you know if there's an audience for
a conservative podcast or this or that
you can go out there and get it but
you're gonna get what you want and you
know that when I hear how do we all get
along how do we have a better country
how do we have a more sophisticated
politics take a look in the mirror it's
you you're the people we the people we
vote for people we govern ourselves at
least for now at least mostly although
that we give that power away time and
time again and in the midterm elections
we're gonna see what people want that's
all that's all I got today I know we ran
out of time said I had more to talk
about we'll talk about it tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
tomorrow
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you